du beatbox à la flûte de pan et tous les
styles ici il n'y a qu'un pas n'hésitons
pas il n'ya qu'un pas et pas pour rire
parce que vous nous disiez que vous
faisiez ont ces magnifiques tran concert
mais j'ai un numéro de pitreries que
j'appelle parce que j'ai écrit des
musiques pour flûte de pour vous même un
vire et et orgue ou harpe
c'est à dire que je joue j'ai à peu près
2 à fait intéressant vous participerez à
la prochaine édition de la compétition
bbox à mort par deux fois pour vous
présenter ni pardon vous êtes parce que
vous êtes un artiste aux multiples
facettes c'est quand même intéressant
vous êtes à la fois compositeur musicien
et inventeur enseignants bon c'est une
grosse définition en effet et donc pas
évident ont le point commun dans tout ça
c'est la flûte de pan
qu'est ce qui vous a amené à travailler
s'est lentement je jouais déjà de la
flûte à bec flûte traversière dont il ya
quelques années quand j'étais beaucoup
plus jeune
et puis j'ai découvert la flûte de pan
vers l'âge de 20 ans en gros j'ai
d'abord eu l'idée de fabriquer une flûte
de pan pour décorer ma chambre mais
vraiment peu de temps après je me suis
dit pourquoi finalement ce que j'en
jouerai pas et puis j'ai abandonné tous
les autres instruments pour jouer que de
la flûte de pan parce que si vous disiez
là vous vous la vie fabriquez vous avez
survécu toute l'afrique puisque j'ai
même améliorer le système c'est à dire
que je fais beaucoup de concerts en
église un fils de par ailleurs vu nulle
part ailleurs kate c'est le cas depuis
30 ans déjà
eh bien j'avais beaucoup de problèmes
lorsque j'ai accordé mais chut
traditionnellement avec de la cire
d'abeille comme c'était depuis des
millénaires et j'ai remplacé la cire
d'abeille par des pistons qui fait que
dans chaque tuyau j'ai mis des petits
bouchons en liège avec un écrou serti
dans le petit bouchon en liège et avec
une sexualité je peux tirer pousser les
pistons qui permet d'accorder très vite
et ça il faut quand même le souligner
vous avez breveté la dépose un brevet
passion et c'est est commercialisé dans
une quarantaine de pays je crois vous
pouvez peut-être nous jouer un morceau
que vous avez là
un morceau pour juste pour préciser les
choses on le sait pas mais vous avez
interprété de nombreux airs notamment
pour des publicités j'ai également
participé va là pour signer ma rencontre
et j'étais avec lui peut-être
pouvez-vous en effet nous de jouer
amenèrent qui va nous dire quelque chose
allez dire à part le café est alors donc
vous vous à votre actif vous avez 15
albums vous avez également reçu neuf
jusque dehors disent que dans votre
dernier album celui ci voyage sur un air
de flûte de pan
c'est ce sont des musiques que j'ai
composées à travers tous mes voyages à
travers le monde quoi et puis alors
votre acte iv actualité très très simple
c'est que vous donner un concert le 2
juin à l'église de bailly à l'église le
valier un concert qui associe flûte de
pan et au regard des orgues
celles ci ont dit j'ai un look très
original d'un concert pour le lions club
international et dont la recette sera
intégralement intégralement reversés
pour les enfants handicapés et d'où vous
est venue cette idée alors d'associer
les ces deux instruments l'orgue la fête
de par ailleurs parce que c'est déjà
comme lors son regard ça ressemble
vraiment un ordre puisque la flûte de
pan c'est l'ancêtre de l'orgue c'est un
grec qui est appelée s'applique-t-elle
steve-o ce qui est l'idée de réaliser
une flûte de pan beaucoup plus grand
qu'il en appelait depuis un an mais
c'est vraiment le même système
moi lorsque je souffle je formais avec
l'élève sorte de sifflet c'est le la
base de chaque tuyau d'eau on retrouve
les mêmes
un petit sifflet en quelque sorte c'est
de forme conique à la base alors sur
francis vidil donc il vous accompagne
donc et organiste et vous accompagne
pour ce récital dont qui n'a
malheureusement pas pu venir sur le
plateau ce fort mais nous l'avons
rencontré hier à l'église de lévis un an
et il va nous donner il va nous
expliquer justement ce que ça représente
pour lui
l'association de ces deux instruments à
l'école on parle de vibrations en
musique
mais on parle de vibrations dans
l'univers scientifique vous disent que
l'univers n'est que vibrations et la
vibration de la flûte de pan réveille en
nous quelque chose de très archaïque
parce que c'est probablement le premier
instrument de musique
parce qu'il ait agi avec le souffle et
que le souffle l'équivalent de la
création divine
que la flûte de pan rajoute alors d qui
lui un petit peu statique sur le plan de
la conduite sonore puisque le vent et
réguler appelé par des mécanismes le
flûtiste lui naturellement à tout son
souffle humain avec ses possibilités de
d'ondulations de chaleur de froideur et
ses limites et qui font que l'instrument
est vraiment touchant
non
tables virtuelles gérées en garde
baissée mouse et francis lamy est
vraiment me fait partie des meilleurs
organistes de france
alors qu'est ce que vous allez
interpréter le alors le 2 juin prochain
à l'église de bailly donc des pièces de
bach mozart erik satie du classique en
général et également d une musique de
ennio morricone parce que j'ai eu le
bonheur vraiment ça je peux dire sur des
moments exceptionnels de ma vie de
travailler avec ennio morricone alors
pour avoir une idée de ses airs
classiques je vous propose d'écouter un
morceau donc un ave maria de schubert
que vous avez donc interprété également
avec voilà allemand la même église avec
francis franc succès
e
alors donc georges on rappelle que les
fonds qui sont récoltées donc iront pour
la fondation lion's-club et puis on
rappelle donc la date c'est le 2 juin à
17h30 à l'église de ben ali et vous avez
un site internet aussi en w le vef un
joueur je suis pointé cette affiche
avait mentionné ennio morricone pouvait
faire quelques notes vous savez
travailler avec nous
j'ai pas la bonne flûte mais je vais
essayer vraiment ce qui s'était vraiment
pas prévu
merci beaucoup